hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to keep in mind now this is
supposedly an emotional game and I don't
know exactly what it covers but it's
supposed to be dark scary and intriguing
Jonas honey are you awake I know you
aren't sleeping why won't you talk to me
is it something I've done each night you
drink until you can't speak and the
morning comes and you just forget
everything including me every night we
fight to keep a conversation going every
night I fight to keep you conscious if
we just talked about it we could be
happy again I feel so far from you oh
that's sad uh-huh
where where am I I think this is this
looks like my home but that's impossible
oh hello we've entered the anti world I
need to get out of here something's gone
very wrong yeah no joke that might be a
summary of this game man this is off to
a rocketing start holy [ __ ]
hello can I interact with anything
apparently not okay
well well well I think I remember that
noise from SCP containment breach but
I'm not sure in fact you look like that
SCP what is it 6 8 - I can't remember
the number of it can it really be our
Jonas come here let me get a good look
at you it has been such a long time ok
alright I'm good I'm coming over there
don't mind me um please make my way down
down oh boy
well I'm glad you've come to visit us
again I know it must be hard to find the
time in your busy pathetic life
that blank look on your face don't tell
me you've forgotten again how sad you
don't even recognize me how does anyone
forget well here's honest if you can't
figure it out you'll be doomed to wander
here forever making the same mistake
over and
you probably never escaped you know you
might as well not even try but if you're
so keen to leave curious mullet I'll
give you a look around isn't this all
just a bit familiar I encourage you to
give all the voices here a good listen
they are more familiar than you think
okay ah thank you all right I'll be on
my way weird mysterious wolf worm you
are lovely and horrifying I go in here
nope
okay there's less to interact with than
I do
where did I go where did I come from
where did I go
danger yeah I'll go there ah huh huh Olo
well this is awfully convenient I don't
know if I'm supposed to be going here
first but this is just where my feet
have carried me oh hi who are you I hate
this job
huh-huh I want to go home they said I
could go home today
they said that yesterday okay good
goodbye
Hui oh hi who the hell are you hi hey I
think I'm finally alone they stopped
chasing me they won't find me back here
no one will ever find me again so why
can i still hear them
well I I mean I found you I don't know
if that means you were that well-hidden
I don't think I can go up yeah no and I
can't run so I'm not gonna go anywhere
quickly that's for damn sure can't go
that way either this is probably a dead
end over this way so I'm are you the
cousin of the wolf worm
aren't you scab you killed your brother
your mother your marriage and your mind
now it's your turn
aren't you scared no not particularly
because I don't know what the Frick is
going on here so how could I be scared
at anybody I come home oh boy you
friends nothing matters anymore
getting up is a chore have nothing to
look forward to she's already given up
on me and I gave up on myself long ago
this one looks tall enough oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no I
all right good talk good conversation
glad glad we could interact and stuff
okay well this is a bizarre game but
what I'm getting from this is that these
are his inner demons cuz I mean the
opening scene was obviously he was
struggling with certain things on his
own and he wasn't he was like self
sabotaging sabotaging his marriage
sabotaging any relationships he's had
and he's like eating away himself for
whatever reason we don't know yet but
I'm imagining we're gonna piece together
those lock those lock doors luck no no
no no no no no I did me grow believe it
was only for a second
forgive me forgive me forgive me okay I
forgive you I for one for you oh boy oh
god no no we'll see the blood the Lord
was me
I can't hide the trail follows me
everywhere
this blood follows me airier okay wow
man I don't know what you did dude but
it bad it was is apparently bad it's
more than just like it's more than just
um it's more than just him being sad
this is like there's something big okay
hang on before I go you're new where'd
you work you over there before I haven't
slept in three days
I'm checked the back door three times
there did you see that quickly
close your eyes he can't see you if you
can't see him okay who are you talking
about you talking about wolf farm down
there wolf arm ain't so bad you just
need to get to know him I rest up my
insides in place of all the things I
never said all I can taste is blood
all I ever taste is blood blood isn't so
bad oh my god what is happening in here
what's happening I have no idea I don't
even know how many of these guys have
actually talked to this is a new area
over here I wonder if oh no what
delightful's oh oh are you salting the
river with your tears oh so tired I've
never been this tired I'm so empty I've
never been this empty maybe this river
can carry me far away I don't even know
what to make of it yet
like the could these all be like the
voices of doubt that plagued this guy's
head I mean he's walking around he's the
only bit of color in this thing besides
blood of course cuz that's common theme
oh hi you look familiar
disgusting what an insignificant
creature around disgusting in
significance disgusting creatures
deserve the mud so keep squirming in the
mud little insect okay thank you hello
headless weird I want to live inside you
like it's a form you could pull I
believe you ahahaha okay thank you
thanks thank thank thank you oh boy
playground that's probably good should
be ball that sounds cool ah hello so
warm in my belly
mmm when I'm empty but run maybe be more
than I need them oh boy
oh boy I don't know what inner voice
that would be but we remember him the
guilts medicine - it's your fault no
it's your fault
you weren't paying attention it was your
job to watch him slip thud crack now
he's gone because of you because of you
because of me man oh jeez okay I've got
15 of 16 I don't know how many more more
more familiar there's one more lurking
about so I'll be right back when I find
Oh
hello you are new I have not met you you
want to be friends I've counted the
grass blades in this field every single
one of them holy [ __ ] this is a specific
quantity for everything
an ideal this tree for example the tree
this tree has ten apples ten apples only
no more than ten absol absolutely no
more than ten apples ten ten ten ten
okay cool so who's knocking on my door
hello hi should I be worried I'm worried
can I go back in home now maybe that's
not my home hi oh there's my home
they're more familiar than you think oh
oh oh I got a chill down my spine
Hey hello all right what do I do
I am self denied every feeling you
blocked out every joy you denied
yourself I am more human than you will
ever be I'm not gonna be able to do all
the voices again so I'm just gonna read
normally I am panic oh god no no no I
failed it you failed me and now we must
pay
I'm guilt as in mine I watched the
mistake you made over and over and then
I watch your brother die before my eyes
and I watch you do nothing and I watch
you do nothing over and over only you
can decide to be whole again so it's
talking about grief I am reclusion gasp
gasps I am everything you ran from every
unpleasant thing shoved back inside they
can't climb my walls can't find what
I've stored in this shell but you can
i'm paranoia there do you see them every
fabricated lie they all swarm around my
head ceases why won't they leave me be
make them leave Jonas I am suppression I
taste every feeling you've swallowed I
feel them crawling its throat I can feel
them burning my belly I think I'm dying
you're killing me Jonas I am decay I'm
waiting for you Jonas Oh chicks that's
all okay you didn't speak please
I am so have left me a mangled rich you
did not deserve to leave his place okay
thank you I'm hopelessness I am
everything you gave up on the lovers you
left behind on the people you could have
been but now there's nothing left
there's nothing left but you you must
have hope
I am addiction on everything you used to
forget haha the alcohol the drugs even
the porn everything you used to pretend
to exist
hahaha what have you brought me this
time
I am neuroticism I'm everything you
tried to control everything that had to
be perfect all I see is chaos chaos
chaos chaos so many flames too many
flames only you can put out the flames
Jonas you you you you you you I am bird
Wow each day I work tirelessly
pretending my worthless existence means
I carry your world on my shoulders
I'm so tired they'll make me carry it
all Jonas I'm resignation I'm every time
you've given up every sadness you
couldn't bear every time you almost
ended everything I'm being swept away
this can't be the end
red please let me back in I never meant
to go open the door Jonas okay oh hi hi
Jonas ha how are you doing
whoo boy whoo hello hi friend
hi friend how you doing friends let me
get a good side by side of you yeah
that's the stuff who would that looks
good
that's nice okay anyway so
you finally mustered up the courage to
crawl through your filthy mind and fine
yeah you are pathetic don't you know
what's going on here are you too stupid
to figure it out
our bribes you don't want to you must
like squirming in the dark like a maggot
you have spent so much time in this
place my place don't you realize these
are your thoughts your memories your
guilts and your obsessions and they all
hate you they all hate you for what
you've done to keep you chained here to
make you pay for the suffering they've
endured it and that's not all is it your
brother is dead because of you you let
him die because you weren't watching
soon your marriage will suffer the same
fate
you flounder in your guilt and anger and
let yourself rot every chance at a life
worth living gone you're afraid to be
alone with your thoughts so you try to
drown them but you don't realize though
those voices that you've tried Zard the
block will scream more and more loudly
scream until your ears bleed so just
keep covering your ears Jonas because
one day soon you might sink so deep
you'll never hear anything again
stop it just shut up I don't want to
hear it anymore you don't rule me I
don't have to live like this I don't
have to live like you well that's one
way to end it
oh oh hi you're you're new I don't think
I've met you well well well
can it be it certainly has been some
time there's no need to be frightened
dear one this place is safe and I'm not
here to harm you it's so good to see you
again how does it feel to be back
amongst your thoughts this place has
changed much in time as you can see the
you Jonas the place has gone to the dogs
do you remember how was before the
darkness do you remember how it used to
be before your brother passed you were
oh so little
and he used to visit us all the time
we were your best friends don't you see
jealous we are you we loved you once and
we still do but some of us are terribly
confused and frightened that phantom in
the mirror calls himself you has been
keeping you from the truth with his
vicious lies without you this darkness
this darkness suffocates us it has
warped us into something you can hardly
recognize something monstrous but we're
still yours dear Jonas and we long for
the light that warm light that's shown
every day
back when you used to love us back when
you used to love you
what are you doing Jonas why is it so
dark you know what you need to do
you need to forgive yourself
you need to forgive yourself for what
you've done
have to forgive those who have hurt you
only then can you live your life fully
until then we'll all remain here crying
for the warmth of the light
I heard a door alright
Am I am i back home it doesn't look as
though I anything has changed the moon
looks so beautiful tonight don't worry I
will try harder and I won't give up
you will all see the light again
Oh
that was beautiful
oh that was legitimately beautiful at
the end oh man oh that was actually
touching oh man I definitely appreciate
the message of this game I mean at times
in there like it definitely was
heavy-handed but like obviously it's
trying to show meaning for something in
and trying to show grief and I wouldn't
be surprised if the person who made this
game you know was dealing with grief
themselves you know it's an important
message to see it and it's important to
realize that it's easy to be suffocated
by your own your own thoughts and and as
someone I've been through grief before
and it's definitely the same way it's
it's self destruct it it can be so
self-destructive if you let it and but
and but at the end of it like you can
come out of it a better person I've said
before that like you can you the way you
face trauma and grief you know the way
you face it the way you come out of it
like that that shapes who you are as a
person it's important to realize that
your own you're your own worst enemy in
those cases and you gotta fight through
certain things and and also you got to
reach out for help but at the end of the
day you know it's uh it's you and it's
what you do with
the thoughts in your head that really
really change who you are so anyway
thank you sherilyn for making this game
and thank you everybody for watching
this I hope you enjoyed it and you know
I really enjoyed it it was good touching
message and and I really liked that game
and I hope you enjoyed my mediocre voice
acting there sorry if it got annoying at
some point but I was just having fun
with it so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye ah all I
did was open up a can of worms to make
everyone in the audience feel bad
I'm so sorry everybody ah I'm a failure
because